-Here's how it works.
Each round, we'll draw a card,
which tells us what face
we both have to make.
We'll look into our mirrors,
make our faces,
and then reveal them
on the count of 3.
We'll stare at each other
for 10 seconds
while trying to hold our faces.
The first person to crack
a smile, laugh,
or break the face loses.
Let's see what
our first face is. Ready?
Curious beaver.
3, 2, 1...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Who won?
-You won, you won.
-The strain.
There's such strain to
make those faces.
[ Strains ]
-Okay. Disappointed grandma.
3, 2, 1...
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪♪♪
-What is that?
-It's so stupid. I don't know.
-Why is it so hard
to keep a face?
-Oh, this one is
chicken laying an egg.
-Oh, my goodness.
-3, 2, 1...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my God.
-Last one here is...
[ Both laugh ]
...stunned turtle.
Mm-hmm.
All right, 3, 2, 1...
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
Kenan Thompson.
♪♪♪♪
I love you, buddy.
Kenan Thompson, everybody.